[Music]
you know we've been conditioned not to
trust our own common sense anymore which
is why we so often need studies to
confirm the obvious but most of us
don't trust studies either and for good
reason in in most cases so that's not
much help but here's here's one study
that i think we can take to the bank so
to speak
there's a pun there which will make more
sense as we proceed
reading now from an article on the
institute for family studies website
written by rosemary l hopcroft which
sounds like a character in an agatha
christie novel and i don't mean that as
a as an insult
she writes quote in 21st century america
over half of all married couples are
dual earner families and men are no
longer expected to be the sole source of
financial support for their families it
seems therefore that possession of means
would no longer matter as much for men's
marriage prospects while at the same
time it may matter more for women's
marriage prospects yet my new research
published in the journal evolution and
human behavior shows that possession of
means still matters when it comes to
marriage and family formation for men
but not for women
in other words men are going to have an
easier time getting married if they have
money but for women it doesn't matter
much one way or another continuing it
says for men as income increases the
probability of marriage also increases
such that men in the highest income
category are about 57 percentage points
more likely to marry than men in the
lowest income category the same is not
true for women
high income men are more likely than low
income men to marry while income is
unrelated to marriage for women given
that marriage involves choice on both
the man and the woman's part these
results suggest that women are more
likely to choose to marry men with good
financial prospects while a woman's
financial prospects are less important
to men when choosing a marriage partner
now every broke single guy listening to
this right now is certainly well aware
of this dynamic
all too familiar with it
but again these days we need this kind
of research to tell us what we already
know
though many of us have chosen to pretend
we don't know it
a little more from the article says not
only are high income men more likely to
marry they're more likely to stay
married too figure two talking about the
chart
shows the probability of divorce for
those who have been married at least
once and reveals that for men the
probability of divorce declines as
income rises such that men in the
highest income category are about 37
percentage points less likely to divorce
than men in the lowest income category
for women the probability of divorce
increases as income rises perhaps mostly
due to reverse causality and the fact
that divorce uh divorced women are more
likely to have to support themselves
financially for men the results suggest
that women are more likely to divorce
low-income men
than high-income men
now
the cynical interpretation of all this
is that women are materialistic and
superficial and some women are just like
some men are but that doesn't explain
these trends generally speaking as the
study demonstrates and thousands of
years of human experience confirms
women are looking for stability they're
looking for a provider
they value ambition they value work
ethic in a man
and that's anything but superficial to
value those things on the other hand men
simply for the most part don't care
about a woman's career ambitions
they don't want a lazy bump on a log
either but they value and are attracted
to a different sort of energy
and ambition in women
i've said before that my wife is
extremely talented has many skills more
skills than i have and is quite
ambitious but she doesn't have a
professional career she parents
ambitiously
she mothers ambitiously she um pours her
energy into her family she has many
creative talents and always finds
different outlets for them sometimes
she'll find outlets that earn money
sometimes not
but the money doesn't really matter to
me
um i didn't marry her in hopes that she
would provide an income for me
no man gets married for that reason
even men who are married to working
women as plenty are
still didn't choose those women because
of their income potential
women hopefully aren't choosing men
solely on income but the man's ability
to provide for his family will be a
major factor in her decision
for men it's just not
men are not thinking about that
they're not thinking when it when
they're when they're with a woman and
think about marriage not that well she
would do great at
providing an income for the family
if they think that she can they may see
that as a bonus but that's they're not
making decisions based on that
and it also doesn't mean by the way that
low-income men low-income single men are
out of luck a woman is also assessing
potential
so even if you aren't making much money
now
she might still consider you an
excellent match if she sees that you
work hard and have aspirations and the
drive to achieve them women are good at
this by the way they have a natural
intuition about these sorts of things
a good wife will often have a clearer
idea of her husband's career potential
than he does
she can't anticipate his future success
even if his predictions about his own
future are far more modest than hers
what this all means
boiled down is that men and women are
different
and they want different things
our cultural institutions have spent
years and decades trying to collapse
these two categories into one ambiguous
indistinguishable mess
and yet in spite of that
still these fundamental differences
remain
girls are told from a young age i mean
it's hammered into their heads
that they shouldn't look to men to be
providers
and boys are told that they shouldn't
see themselves in that role
and yet
both groups gravitate this way anyway
attempts are made to evade these
differences get around them
and most of these attempts end in
disaster
note how a woman's likelihood of divorce
increases as her income increases
while the trend is exactly the opposite
for men and that's because
women are attracted to men who provide
so if he pours himself into that role as
provider
the woman's attraction will grow
stronger and deeper
of course some men can go too far they
prioritize their careers over their
families
and many divorces have happened as a
result of that but as long as he's
putting his family first and valuing his
job in large part because he values his
family and takes his provider role
seriously then it should only strengthen
his marriage
yet a woman who invests herself more and
more into the into her career is not
going to find that it has the same
positive effect on her marriage
necessarily because her husband doesn't
fundamentally see her as a provider he
may support her career
but he doesn't find her career ambition
attractive in the same way that a woman
does for a man
and the there are a lot of men who
listen who are listening to this right
now and feel like they have to disagree
with me and say no that's not true i my
my woman is my wife is a
very ambitious in her career and a great
business woman
and i just find it so sexy and
attractive
and no you don't not really i mean
you're saying that because you think you
have to but you don't
really again thousands and thousands of
years of of of human behavior tell us
the truth here
and also if the woman becomes more
successful in her career than than the
man is in his it can lead to resentment
because the man will begin to feel that
he has no essential role that he's no
longer necessary
this is not me prescribing how things
should be i'm just describing how they
are and always have been
we've been conditioned to recoil from
the notion of gender roles the term
almost always is used in a pejorative
way now
but at their root
gender roles were never rules
it wasn't society saying what men and
women
should do or most must do gender roles
were our way of categorizing what men
and women already naturally tend to do
and it's good to have a grasp on that
because without it couples go into
marriage not sure what to do or what
their role should be
invariably they end up stepping on each
other's toes competing with rather than
complimenting each other
this is why it's good to have a healthy
understanding of and respect for
traditional gender roles quote unquote
even if you're going to do something
different in your own family
it's good to know what the original
recipe is before you come up with your
variation of it
what happens these days is that both the
man and the woman stand in the kitchen
dumping all kinds of competing
ingredients into the bowl mixing it
together and the end result is confused
and weird and rarely successful
and that's the result of trying to deny
what we all inherently know to be true
so who are we canceling today we're not
canceling gender roles because those
can't be cancelled not completely
instead i guess this is another reverse
cancellation we're canceling the people
who have tried to cancel the gender
roles
because that's just never actually going
to work if you enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up and share it
with all your friends